millones de personas confían en la
cafeína para levantarse por la mañana
eso es cierto probablemente aunque en mi
caso si toma un poco de cafeína por la
mañana no puedo dormir esa noche aquí se
presentan datos nutricionales de algunas
bebidas populares de la cafetería bends
vince entonces aquí tenemos los nombres
de algunas bebidas y para cada una de
esas bebidas sabemos si son calientes o
frías cuántas calorías tiene cuánta
azúcar y cuánta cafeína muy bien ahora
con esto tratemos de responder a estas
preguntas y como siempre pausa en el
vídeo e intenten responder las preguntas
por ustedes mismos antes de que yo lo
haga así que los individuos en este
conjunto de datos son y cuando vemos el
término individuos probablemente pienses
de inmediato que estamos hablando de
personas porque en el lenguaje diario
cuando hablamos de individuos nos
referimos a personas pero en el lenguaje
estadístico nos estamos refiriendo a las
diferentes entradas del conjunto de
datos así que cada uno de los renglones
del conjunto de datos no se refieren a
tipos de personas o clientes
cosas de sus clientes no es sobre los
clientes de vending
cada uno de estos renglones representa
cada una de las bebidas que se ofrecen
en la cafetería vending
así que esos son los individuos el
lenguaje estadístico los individuos se
pueden referir a cosas cuáles son las
cosas representadas en este conjunto de
datos
luego nos preguntan sobre el contenido
de ese conjunto de datos
cuántas variables son y si son
categóricas o no en primer lugar que es
una variable bueno las variables son las
cosas que son diferentes en estas
entradas sobre estos individuos y que
nos dicen cosas sobre ellos en esta
tabla en este conjunto de datos y bueno
el nombre es una variable cada una de
estas bebidas tiene un nombre diferente
esta es una variable el tipo es variable
pueden ser calientes o frías las
calorías son variables el contenido de
azúcar es variable y la cafeína es
variable así que aquí tenemos 5
variables el nombre el tipo calorías
azúcar y cafeína y si tenemos 5
variables podemos descartar las opciones
de 6 variables que tenemos aquí abajo
así que descartamos ésta
y descartamos está
y ahora cuántas de estas son categóricas
una variable categórica
significa que esa dimensión de la cosa
que estás metiendo va a caer en algunas
categorías o que esta variable toma
valores que son nombres de una categoría
así que por ejemplo el nombre de la
bebida es una variable categórica porque
los valores que puede tomar esta
variable son en realidad los nombres de
las bebidas y estas son las categorías
puede ser un café preparado un café
latte un café moca un capuchino y así
sucesivamente entonces esta variable que
tenemos aquí es categórica
y podrías preguntarte cuál es otro tipo
de variable bueno otro tipo de variable
es la variable cuantitativa
una variable cuantitativa va a tomar
valores numéricos en contraposición a
los valores categóricos valores
numéricos que están midiendo algún tipo
de atributo así que vamos a ver aquí
tenemos tipo y el tipo no es un valor
numérico está tomando el valor de una
categoría va a ser caliente o frío así
que esta variable también es categórica
pero estas otras tres tienen valores
numéricos que representan en el caso de
las calorías el número de calorías que
tiene una porción la cantidad de azúcar
en la variable de azúcar con la cantidad
de cafeína en la variable cafeína así
que estas tres que están aquí son
variables cuantitativas entonces tenemos
un total de cinco variables dos de las
cuales son variables categóricas y tres
son variables cuantitativas entonces
esta es nuestra respuesta cinco
variables dos de las cuales son
categóricas y las variables categóricas
son el nombre cuál es el nombre de la
bebida y si la bebida es caliente o fría